more and more in North America young
people are not content just to get
pierced or tattooed they want to make a
personal statement in scholars they're
getting their flesh burned with searing
hot metal they're getting branded until
yesterday
Tyler Ballentine had never set foot in
New York City but Tyler has not really
come to see the sights he's in New York
for just one reason to get a brand at
home in Toronto Canada
Tyler works as a professional body
piercer so far he has pierced himself 16
times including the holes he has
stretched in his earlobes he's part of a
growing subculture in North America that
its devotees call body modification body
modification reshape their bodies from
tattoos to scarification to implanting
objects under their skin body modifiers
admit much of what sets them apart is
dangerous and excruciating ly painful
but nothing they say feels or smells
like having your skin melted away with
burning hot steel
even for his brand Tyler has turned to
Brian Decker a fellow body modifier time
yeah how low do you want to go sorry I'm
about halfway I got here to Tyler his
brand represents freedom specifically
his freedom to modify his body any way
he wants unlike branders of the past
Brian will burn Tyler's arm inch by inch
it will take several hours
oh is him right now in this circumstance
I definitely be nervous Tyler knows
there's a very real chance he may simply
not be able to take it by law Brian
cannot give him an anesthetic
Brian's only tools are a wedge of
stainless steel a vise grip and a
blowtorch from the first strike the pain
is excruciating heated to at least 1,000
degrees Fahrenheit the steel instantly
vaporizes Tyler skin even after the
metal is removed the tissue continues to
burn Brandon is so torturous Tyler is
running the risk his body could go into
shock at the very least his inflamed
skin will remain susceptible to
infection for days to come a
third-degree burn if you don't take care
of a third-degree burn
that's definitely possibility for an
infection they obviously could spread
gradually Tyler grows accustomed to the
pain and he is able to lay still and
watch Bryan finish he's gonna look
decent he and all the process has taken
five hours and despite the torment
Tyler is content with his accomplishment
that question he didn't quit and he's
gotten another unique mark to signal his
identity it hurt really bad but what
just made it all the more worse was the
smell of it and hearing my skin pop I
know there's gonna be mixed reactions
there's gonna be people calling me nuts
but that's kind of the beauty of
modifications because you get to be able
to see who actually looks into people
really it doesn't really matter what you
look like it shouldn't matter at all
for body modifiers brands are not just
an extreme way to signify their status
as social rebels they're also keys to a
separate and very elite club they can
call their own